bonjour jeunes berg merci de répondre à
nos questions qu'est ce que vous
attendez du discours de vladimir poutine
tout à l'heure j'attends une
réaffirmation de sa politique
traditionnelle qui est une politique qui
repose sur quelques mots la souveraineté
toutes les décisions sont prises par le
pouvoir russe pour bien du peuple russe
une autonomie également nous dépendons
pas de puissance extérieure nous menons
notre politique et une troisième je
crois un troisième pilier nous sommes
fidèles à nos amis quelles que soient
leurs manquements leurs difficultés même
leurs erreurs
nous nous avons qu'une parole nous
abandonnons personne surtout lorsqu'ils
ont été lus on verra des commencent à se
poursuivre évidemment ça s'applique à en
à l'habile russie mais également à tous
les partenaires de la russie dans le
monde donc vladimir poutine est sorti
d'un trimestre à 6 difficile où le
corona virus ça va des élections
provinciales qui ont eu lieu le 13
marqué par cette malheureuse affaire
navalni il s'en est relativement bien
tiré à la fois parce que sauf quelques
quelques indépendants dans les conseils
municipaux c'est le parti au pouvoir qui
a été lu pratiquement dans toutes les
régions donc stabilité du pouvoir malgré
toutes les difficultés sanitaires
économiques
et puis les perturbations extérieures
donc il ya quand même une grande
résilience de vladimir poutine dont la
cote est toujours autour de 60% une cote
à une cote que beaucoup de dirigeants
occidentaux envieraient donc voilà lancé
rapport aux dirigeants occidentaux
comment est ce que vous avez trouvé
donne un tram tout à l'heure les à vis
de la russie
bon vous avez réussi l'un pas tellement
parler vous savez qu'il ay le in à une
attaque jamais frontalement son ami ou
partenaires vladimir poutine simplement
ce que j'en déduis c'est que il a une
politique très dure vis-à-vis de la
chine et de l'iran
qui sont deux grands partenaires de la
russie donc manifestement il attaqua
directement la russie
il aimerait pratiquement décrocher la
russie de la chine
mission évidemment impossible dans les
conditions actuelles et surtout la
manière dont il prend également l'iran
donc il n'a pas parlé de la turquie bien
entendu la pas parler de la syrie
il s'est concentré sur les deux pays qui
sont encore une fois des grands
partenaires quel que soit le régime
politique qu'est ce quelle que soit la
leur vie politique interne et on a même
forgé le l'acronyme bric russie iran
chine le nouvel empire mongol bon on va
loin je rappelle qu'ils sont quand même
tous membres de l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai qui est un peu
l'hôte le pendant toute proportion
gardée de l'otan à l'est et donc c'est
une grande agglomération de force et ça
je crois que il est impossible donald
trump d'ébranler s'était dit fils qui
existent et qui va prospérer quoi qu'on
en dise
donald trump son discours a duré six
minutes 1 il a pris la parole à 16h02
heure française il l'a rendue à 16h08
exactement c'était une brève allocution
très axé sur sur la chine très critique
envers l'empiré du milieu idem à
vis-à-vis de l'onu c'est un discours
manifestement électorale puisque il va
faire bon on rentre on sort un peu de la
russie mais c'est quand même il y est il
va dire moi je suis le seul homme
capable d'affronter la chine puisse on
s'oriente vers une nouvelle guerre
froide sur les retraites écrire là
dessus donc je suis un domaine que je
connais c'est une nouvelle guerre froide
justement ce sont les mots avant tout à
l'heure en ouverture 1-2 de cette 75e
session de l'assemblée générale de l'onu
les mots d'antonio goûter reste
secrétaire général de l'omm
à dix j'appelle à éviter une nouvelle
guerre froide justement il part donc des
etats-unis de la russie de la chine
vous qui écrivez là-dessus du coup ça
veut dire quoi il parle pour la guerre
froide opposait deux camps états unis
avec l'otan eurent ce pacte de varsovie
maintenant on a un affrontement entre
états unis et chine
la grande différence si vous permettez
c'est que la l'union soviétique
participera pas au commerce mondial aux
investissements alors c'était c'était un
ou deux pour cent du commerce mondial
maintenant la chine représente 12 à 13
donc il ya une bonne avance et une
bataille idéologique
politico-stratégique c'était les
armements nucléaires mais il y avait
pratiquement pas sauvegarde qu'acheter
les allemands n'y avait pas de rapports
économiques au moins au début se sont
faits dans les années 70 80
maintenant on à l'affrontement qui est
en partie de société andy pas
idéologique
finalement la chine elle veut pas qu'on
lui donne des fins des leçons elle veut
être souveraine à l'intérieur je n'ai
aucune leçon à recevoir des états unis
d'ailleurs de n'importe quel pays mais
par contre il ya un affrontement
technologique on le voit que why
commercial et en même temps donc une
volonté de décrochage décerné par
rapport à la chine
donc c'est ça la guerre froide faute de
mieux on a trouvé ce terme mais encore
une fois ce n'est pas un affrontement
identique
cette fois ci il est beaucoup il est
frontale et il porte finalement sur le
coeur même de notre existence
c'est-à-dire l'économie la technologie
le numérique et les sciences de l'avenir
c'est quelque chose qui ne va pas
disparaître comme ça au pab avec
quelques conférences c'est fondamental
et donc voilà pourquoi le le secrétaire
général a sonné la sonnette d'alarmé en
disant il ne faut pas que ce fossé
technologique s'accroissent autrement on
aura une balkanisation du monde et lui
qui est le le prototype enfin disons le
porte-parole de multi et réalisme il ne
sera que perdant puisque le nu sera plus
en plus une coquille vide puisque
l'affrontement dépassera l'onu et
brisera le multilatéralise regard des
états unis est sortie de l'unesco il est
sorti de l'eau
s il est sorti de tous les accords donc
pratiquement jamais du niveau physique
n'a fait ça pendant les pires pilote de
la guerre froide
au contraire elle a réintégré toutes ces
organisations vous voyez donc là on est
devant un cas de figure qui est très
nouveau qui est préoccupant mais encore
une fois il faut voir comment va se
développer après les élections puisque
manifestement trump lorsqu'il s'adresse
il s'adresse à son électorat pour pour
ramener en quelque sorte en disant je
suis le seul homme fort qui peut
s'opposer à tous les autres y compris
qui j'ai pu y compris les autres et
poutine je le ménage parce que
finalement je voyais jugé comme certain
intérêt à garder le dialogue et ne pas
l'affronter
nous sommes en tant que l'avenir
politique qui va s'exprimer d'ici
quelques instants on l'a dit on le
répète là c'est toujours sebastian
pinera qui garde la parole le président
chilien
d'ici quelques minutes le discours de
vladimir poutine
gène bergues cette année c'est une 75e
assemblée générale particulière on l'a
dit il ya le coronavirus il y à des
visioconférences
ce qui veut dire qu'il n'ya pas des
tractations de couloirs des discussions
en coulisses pour ça qu'il ya des
petites salles du côté du grand bâtiment
de l'onu
des fils salle où il ya beaucoup de
discussions entre chefs d'état 2 à 3 4 à
c'est là où on prend les décisions il ya
aussi un hôtel à côté on parle
d'ascenseur diplomatique où on va
également se voir et lui faire des
déjeuners et tout ça cette fois ci on
peut pas le faire comment on fait du
coup comment vous vladimir poutine ou ou
donald trump ou si jean ping vont faire
pour prendre des décisions cette année
évidemment je vais bien écoutez moi je
fus j'ai fait partie des délégations
française et l'onu dans les années 70-80
donc je sais un peu comment ça se passe
et si on va on peut faire une
vidéoconférence lorsqu on expose le
point de vue d'un pays mais lorsqu'on va
à l'onu notamment en reste deux trois
jours eh bien on voit une quarantaine ce
on commence à 7h du matin avec un petit
déjeuner on entame avec une couverture
presse à 8 heures donc on voit
énormément le jean et ses contacts sont
indispensables si le contact humain
par exemple on voit ses amis les uns les
africains les autres les latino
américains et puis surtout on se voit
entre quat'z'yeux d'homme à homme
ça évidemment c'est une grande perte on
ne peut pas le remplacer
on l'a vu à 27 ans le voit mais il reste
pas moins qu'il est il était bon de
garder évidemment cette session vidéo
conférence puisque finalement ya les
discussions mais il faut pas oublier
qu'un diplomate un chef d'état il est il
il parle un peu pour la postérité pour
l'histoire son discours est scruté par
les experts les journalistes et c'est
finalement l'exposé à un moment donné de
sa politique de ses objectifs
souvent il faut le lire entre les lignes
donc tu au discours rentrer dans
l'histoire plus ou moins importants et
donc c'est ça aussi le rôle d'une
assemblée générale
ces deux discours d'exposer au monde au
sens large sur l'arène internationale
ses positions de les défendre et ensuite
de discuter alors évidemment le deuxième
volet discussion il est il a disparu
c'est bien dommage mais que voulez-vous
j'espère que l'empereur
ce reviendra merci jeanne d'arc d'avoir
répondu à nos questions restées un
évidement avec nous puisque après le
discours de vladimir poutine et bien on
débriefera l'allocution du président
russe je rappelle que vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur spécialiste de la russie
auteur notamment de la russie pour les
nuls aux éditions first